hello my name's Simon I'm not like
overly tight clothing which accentuates
my nipples if you didn't get that
reference that you should probably go
and watch my series of videos I did
recently on getting ready for exams and
study reviewers have been calling it
pec-tacular how do you look at that
there was this really baggy t-shirt just
lying around so this is just gonna be a
quick update vlog keeping you up to date
on what I've been up to but also letting
you guys know that some interesting
projects and talking a little bit about
what videos they're gonna be on this
channel in the near future spoiler alert
it's quite a few first up some links
view if you found my recent series on
the studying techniques useful or if
you're just interested in proving your
studying technique or preparing for an
exam I really really recommend you check
out YouTube channel called college info
geek so revival Thomas Frank and he is
an American student going from college
and he's doing an awful constantly
similar to what and myself and Jamie do
so if you are interested in improving
your studying go and check him out he's
done his videos are really really good
that way better produce than mine and
they're really green formative so go
check those out and tell them I said hi
next if you're thinking of applying to
Oxford then make sure at 7:30 this
Tuesday you are tuning in to the Oxford
log Channel you don't know Ochs blog is
the collaboration vlogging project I set
up an Oxford weather at six students
from across the university talking about
their daily lives and this Tuesday there
are doing a live stream now if you enjoy
the live students that Jake Jimmy and
myself have done before make sure you
check this out I think everyone from the
channel is going to be there I'm not
gonna be on but the six of them are
gonna be answering your questions live
so if you have any questions about
applying to Oxford or maybe if you've
got an offer and you'd like to know how
to pair or what to expect then make sure
you there 7:30 GMT this Tuesday next
some of you might remember that a few
weeks ago in one of my blogs I talked
about group called semitone her from
University of Exeter now I talked about
them folks they just released an EP but
they just won the Reapers that is best a
cappella group in the country award a
voice festival and they've uploaded
their set from the final about
competition on YouTube if you are even
very interested in music go and check it
out it's 10 minutes the youth beats so
glad that you spent what
is it absolutely amazing and lastly just
a quick reminder that I have my own
public Facebook page now which is
facebook.com for slashing YouTube's
Simon and I promised on there that if
that hits a hundred likes I'll post the
video of me doing the cinnamon challenge
so if you like the sound of me basically
almost dying then make sure you go over
the link in the description and like
that are you put all the videos from
here on there and I'm also doing a post
every day at the moment to provide some
motivation awesome revision break
material if you guys who have to pay for
exams so link down below make sure you
go like it so I've been really busy
recently works actually we're going
credibly well so Elizabeth you are new
here I'm a PhD student in climate
physics that extant and my project is on
what's called stratosphere troposphere
capital and recently I've been looking
at the physics behind
fluid in the atmosphere moving in and
out of the polar region basically now
I've actually getting to the point where
I'm getting quite close to solving the
equation for the basic version of what
I'm looking at so I've been spending a
lot of time - I spent days recently just
holidays where I've just been doing
algebra on one problem and that's really
cool cuz that's actually why I start
doing the PhD I like I've always loved
just tinkering with equations and
playing around with the algebra
basically but that's that's actually
coming to a head now and I'm currently
preparing to go to the rule
Meteorological Society student
conference in Birmingham which I will
hopefully do a vlog about because that's
a few days where basically PhD students
from all over the country converge and
the University of Birmingham and I
should be giving a presentation which I
might see if I get something filmed for
me we'll see later the yeah I've
actually been making some real progress
and work which is great because IVF sees
one these things where it can stall you
know you can feel like you're just
bashing head against a brick wall you're
not getting in progress and especially
when you've got friends who writing
their papers or even old friends you're
writing your thesis and you know it's
really difficult sometimes to stay
motivated to keep going when you just
feel like you're not making any
but a fella can now so that's right on
the subject of my research though I have
been busy writing a series of videos for
this channel where I talk about the
system that I doing with the
stratosphere in the atmosphere and it's
basically gonna serve as a primer for
atmospheric physics bill just a general
understanding of of the atmosphere and
in particular looking in stratosphere
and then we coming up this channel soon
I can't give an exact date yet because I
haven't finished writing them then it's
difficult to condense what's taking me
quite a long time to learn into a video
at a level that's informative but not
confusing for people who haven't gone
through the system already so I've
always finished writing them they will
be out in the next couple of weeks and
that's not all though I've got a lot of
stuff ah so exciting so in addition to
those videos about the stratosphere I
have been busy planning a new video
series which is gonna be the successor
to the Kerbal space program series I did
which for those of you who are new I did
a couple of videos basically explaining
the physics behind rocketry and some of
the history of spaceflight and using
subscribers as my room volunteers to go
through space and possibly dying only
one diving boat wasn't that bad the
spiritual successor to that series
though is going to be me doing by hope
will be a full playthrough of a game
called XCOM enemy Unknown which is
basically a squad based combat game but
you get to customize your soldiers and
what I'm gonna be doing is fighting this
alien menace with a team of physicists
throughout history and every episode
we'll be talking about the achievements
of each of the soldiers under our
command and hopefully trying not to get
some of the greatest minds in Western
history killed I can't make any promises
it's quite a brutal game if you're not
familiar with it so off he's going well
though it's going to be coming out twice
a week but that's not gonna be replacing
regular video content I'm gonna try and
get something regular out every week but
let's see that might be a bit of push
lastly though
five years ago I uploaded a video called
applying to Oxford Cambridge and it was
the first video it loads on this channel
on it was really really bad it was tired
politically bad but it was good enough
to actually get enough used means a week
you know get this channel going but it
was five years ago just a couple days
ago that I have basically my anniversary
with YouTube and the access see the the
admissions side of oxygen Cambridge
online has completely changed in part
because of the work which I've been
doing with people like Jamie Myles and
Jake right and what I'm going to be
doing is an updated version of that
video which basically summarizes
everything about applying to Oxford
Cambridge and it's gonna quite a long
video but it's gonna point you to
resources so it's gonna point you to
things like August we can't vlog and
can't we and Jake's channel basically as
being a one-stop-shop before if you were
interested in applying to Oxbridge this
is the video you watch and it points you
in the direction that you have a
particular question it tells you what
can be answered at least that's the idea
so that'll be coming out very soon and
if you are thinking of applying to
Oxford I really really hope I'll be
useful to you because basically with all
of this content I'm just trying to make
the stuff which I wish I had access to
when I was applying because when I was
applying online there wasn't a huge
amount of information available and now
it's an awful lot better in fact the
problem is there's so much that you
don't really know where to start looking
so I really hope that will be helped I
was actually thinking of doing a Q&A
video to celebrate the whole five year
aspect of things so if you have a
question that's not like in admissions
how many G says ease do I need to get
kind of question then you know for that
done in the comment section and if
there's enough interest and enough
questions then I'll do a Q&A video and
that'll be next week's video and before
then there'll be the first in the XCOM
series that's it from this blog though
stick around and I hope you like all of
that thanks for watching